so if you're not necessarily
experiencing the blank page but you're
collaborating with someone else's work
who's already done that part what's your
process for then breaking down that
script looking at it analyzing it well
I'm the slowest reader in the world like
it will take me six hours to read a
script I don't know why that is I've
kind of read it out loud in my head or
something but what happens because of
that is that I am stuck in every single
moment and that script for a really long
time so I noticed really quickly when
something takes too long whereas a
quicker reader would probably just go
like oh here's a here's a page of
whatever and I'll just continue reading
on I get angry if I'm on a page that
doesn't know what at once and I don't
know why I'm in that scene right now and
I hope the right this sounds very bad
but I kind of hold the writer personally
responsible with wasting my time which
really isn't their fault because I'm
just a slow reader
but at least after reading it I have a
very clear and it might be completely
off objectively but I have a very clear
idea where I felt the script worked or
didn't work and then I just apply I'm a
big big believer in formula as always
working in classic narrative structure
like from Aristotle over I think Robert
McKee is a genius I know a lot of people
think he's to form your leg and he's
whatever but I think that most of the
weaknesses in a narrative when it can't
hold your your attention that is because
it doesn't adhere to a certain narrative
structure if it three-act structure a5x
structure or whatever it is that is
ingrained in us as human beings you know
so I work a lot with question marks for
example like at what at what moment at
this moment in the script what are the
question marks that I as an audience and
burning to have answered that made me
turn the page why am i interested in
continuing this and a lot of time you'll
realize there is no question mark that
people are just having coffee right now
and you know it's a problem and that
goes back to what we're talking about
earlier which is conflict and stakes
cause drama is conflict and stakes that
also means that you do
know what the outcome of something will
be so there is a kind of internal
magnetism and a structure from moment to
moment that I think you have a it's very
easy to get a good feeling for that and
to not be distracted by that's maybe
another thing I'm not a very visual
person isn't I don't see the script in
my head you know at all I feel the story
I read the story I get a feeling for the
characters I don't see images and I
think a lot of other people that do see
the images are kind of seduced by that
and don't necessarily see that the story
is weak you know that the the
cornerstones of the story are not as
powerful as they should be but because I
don't have that visual at all to
distract me I'm always after the moments
that don't live up to their full
potential in what they are trying to do
and that's a very abstract thing that's
it doesn't matter if that happens on a
boat or in space or on whatever is you
know it's always the why should the
audience be at the edge on the edge of
their seat right now
what are they wondering about what do
they want to find out why do they care
what do they identify with those things
you know so it's almost a mathematical
structure which helps me look because it
is basically more or less to start the
same starting point for almost every
script which of course a lot of writers
hate because they collect but my script
is different from there that's great it
is different in subject matter and
content but in the underlying audience
expectation and the rhythm than it
Aldean says in consuming a story it's
not different it's me that's met with
the same expectations so you have to see
it through that lens to know how an
audience is going to react to it I think
you